uh just moments ago crime scene tape was
removed and you can still see there is a
police presence just down the street
from what families tell us the victim
was a father and a husband and a staple
in his community
shots fired on the west side of town
Saturday afternoon around 3 30 p.m Metro
Police confirming that a 54-year-old man
was shot multiple times and killed while
helping his friends jump start a car
outside of his home on Hassel Avenue boy
they were out front working on the
vehicles an unknown suspect uh sounds
like he might have parked a block away
walked up on them and fired shots
striking our victim while police have
yet to confirm the identity of the
victim the family is telling eight news
now his name was William Hill Jr a woman
who didn't want to be named but says she
is the mother of Hill's three children
tells 8 news now that she was just at
UMC where he was taken noting that hill
was the type of man to be there for
everybody he was the best he had a heart
of gold he gave everything to everybody
I'm gonna be strong I have to for my
grandbabies and my other kids we have
three kids together we have two boys and
a girl so I have to be strong for them
police still looking for the suspect
acts but gave this description a known
age black male adult uh wearing possibly
a dark hoodie or dark jacket uh beanie
or dark ball cap police also stating
that the suspect took off heading
Northbound from the scene in a black car
and as for the two friends that were
outside during the shooting they were
not hurt and they are currently in talks
with police reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now